the big fancy theme that makes for unit
integration for you to integration it's
really integration by parts okay a lot
flows out from that and you can sort of
feel really really powerful like I know
what integration my parts is you
mentioned the name of people's like
education what's it you know
yes let me show you this magic and when
you when you actually use the rule it
really does look like magic if you don't
write down the formula it's cut people
will look at and say where did you get
any of that for right now the thing is
it's so powerful at least system um
because it opens up so many avenues for
things you can integrate right it
actually makes the kinds of problems you
encounter so difficult that actually it
spawns whole other subnets underneath it
to deal with that new category of harder
problems that you can now address okay
which is what today's lesson is about so
therefore to make sense of this let's go
back to what integration by parts is by
now hopefully we have the formula for
integration part by parts in our head
we're sorry integral of U DV right so
these are the two things that you have
to choose right what's on the right hand
side you be good - the other the
corresponding u - all right okay good
now what I want to draw to your
attention as you look at this is that
because integration by parts gets an
integral by way of another integral
right sometimes this interval over here
you have noticed it doesn't always just
fall out sometimes it's still something
you have to integrate by parts again
okay
so I just very quickly want to draw your
mind back to an example you have already
done which I think was he goes x squared
DX
okay x squared is yes now let's quickly
rehearse what's this going to be equal
to what would you choose for you and
what would you choose for DV it's not
too hard being that you've got an x
squared DX
clearly one is easier to integrate and
what is going to be more beneficial to
you to differentiate which ones which
you's gonna be a squared isn't it
because when you get your do you over
here the power is going to reduce right
at correspondingly the exes well but you
don't really need to do anything to
really do okay but once you've done this
right when you execute this life here
okay watch what happens d remember
there's UV so they're problems okay but
then when you do this part there's a
factor of two I'm not gonna worry about
it inside the interval you're going to
get this okay now we've been doing this
topic long enough that you recognize the
exceedingly actually like oh I can do
something with this and at the very
least it's better than what I started
with right so then you look at this
thing and you go integration by parts
again right
whoo I wonder if you could do this part
could you do it in your head yet is it
simple enough that we could again the
choice of U and DV is quite obvious
isn't it
right so when I choose my you and my V
which is slightly differently what would
you V be it's going to be X e to the X
isn't it
okay well you've got your VD you what's
going to happen well because U is now X
right do you will just be one so you get
this okay so now we have reached a point
where I can I could deal with this
that's just regular even even to the
integration okay so no problem I can
bring this back to parent my original
question this is going to be x squared e
to the X plus y side by this X it gets -
yes and because I've integrated
everything laughs it constantly unit
there is the thing right you go through
this process hopefully you can see there
is a pattern going on here right for
instance the fact that we had to get do
integration by parts here and what we
had to integrate by parts again you can
see it clearly in the same family is
what I started with in the first place
right I started with x squared e to the
X and then what I had to integrate again
by parts was X e to the X
it's clearly not a coincidence right
mathematicians we're always trying to
see you know things that are
coincidences are patterns so we should
be able to take advantage of that and
express that in some kind of general way
not just with twos and ones or threes
and two or whatever okay can we get this
in a a broad way that couldn't I don't
have to have specific numbers in them
okay so let's consider if you haven't
started writing this because you like
off we did this before you should write
this one okay let's do this you know
where it's not x squared but some
arbitrary value of x to the well I guess
we might call it n okay now in order to
make this easier to work with you've
seen before sometimes it helps to just
call your integral Y right but I'm gonna
have different integrals flying around
as you can see here as he and I want to
be able to distinguish between them I
think so I'm going to define my
subscript M as whichever power of X I'm
after
okay so we'll call this one X okay now
we were looking at up I mean the case we
looked at he was I too wasn't it okay
and you can see as well that I 1 appears
where does it appear right there okay so
you can see I'm going to have different
lies floating around but I'm talking in
abstract to him so it's all ins I don't
actually know what these numbers are
okay but I can still handle them in just
the same way right so watch if I were to
integrate this by parts okay I would
choose
well I'd still make the same choices for
youth and DV wouldn't I
right you'd still put your X ^ whatever
yeah which will give you a do you on DX
off and X n to the minus 1
yep you still chosen this is e to the X
for the same reason we did before so
there's your whoops there's your feet
okay good let's move it to this now and
actually integrate this so here's my UV
X Y X now my VDU I'm gonna take that end
out the front because again just like in
this case it's a constant I don't really
need to worry about it I'm gonna have to
buy this and integral okay V do you okay
now this is what we expected before
right we had n as two so there's two and
the N minus one is one bigger so far so
good but this point because I've defined
Y as this right this is another kind of
I is a tip which one is it it's a it's I
but the the only thing that's a fit is
the power which is n minus 1 so I've got
n lots of I what I look at this for a
second movie ok what is this this is a
very very important line here okay what
you've got is that thing which you hate
in a dictionary right you're like what
what's the meaning of what's a funny
word or [ __ ] would even what's the
meaning of playful it's like you see
play and then you go to play play and
it's like the the act of being playful
that's not helpful right you've got
something defined in terms of itself
okay this is such a crucial idea it has
its own word it's called recursion right
you can hear that the root word in there
right
in English a recurring motif it's the
thing which happens around and around in
circles okay now it's not quite you know
either yet in terms of idea over here we
saw some examples like that I think we
did let's see when we did either the X
sine X I think okay when you evaluated
this you actually got another eye over
on the right hand side you have to bring
it over but they open because - fine
right but here you've got onion and some
previous version of I right but we've
been used to this kind of thing before
right like way back in u7 we learn about
different kinds of sequences and some of
them are best described recursively
what's the big example is one there's
one secrets which are very very very
familiar with but there's actually I
mean there are not recursive definitions
for it but the recursive definition
makes sense the most same I recognize it
what's this series this is the Fibonacci
series right what's the definition of
the Fibonacci series if I want some
arbitrary term and infirm for reasons
the nth Fibonacci term how do you
calculate it you you have to add up the
two previous terms don't you if I wanted
this one for instance I would taking us
these two right if I want to do this one
I'll take you get the idea so how would
I write this I would write as the
previous one plus the one before that
okay this just like this is a recursive
definition okay it just so happens that
this am there's a non recursive
definition for the Fibonacci series but
it's really weird
it's got like even though it's all on
it's all integers it's all four numbers
somehow you've got weird numbers like
this irrational numbers they can be good
too they're creepy it's a non recursive
definition who's to go and ratio it by
the way anyway sorry you're familiar
with this idea of recursion you just
haven't met it for a while and you
certainly haven't seen
in the context of integrals okay but
it's really really useful
let's see what happens I had the case of
my two here right and in because the the
N was quite small you could deal with it
in this way alright and it would be too
difficult but if I increase the power
right you're gonna have to integrate and
then integrate and they need to create
so many times it can get quite confusing
right so we're going to use this idea
here and by the way this line here this
line rather coin a recursive definition
they call that the record recurrence
relation okay it's the same idea as with
Fibonacci they just give it a fancy V
okay this is the recurrence relation for
X n DX okay and we can use this directly
okay for instance if I asked you I'm
Justin gonna increase the power by 1
because I just want to demonstrate the
concept of okay if I asked you to
integrate X let's just push it up to X
cubed okay I could go through this
process and it would work okay right but
it will be faster and more efficient if
I use this and take advantage of it okay
so if I go with this definition what is
this this is I 3 is a that's the case
I'm looking at that's the power right so
I'm gonna go straight to this line okay
this is really kind of intervention by
parts on steroids really it's sort of
taking this part here in automating it
if you like so what is I think by
definition okay you're gonna get back X
cubed in the X there's my X to the M for
this chosen value of n right and then
what happens over here well I'll get
three Lots on fine - dad okay that's
that's the I advice one well I - I could
define in terms of I 1 right what's this
going to be this is going to be X now my
it is 2 x squared e to the X - what's my
Indians
i won okay so you see what I mean that
this this here is doing what we were
doing over here but just automating the
actual process of integration all right
I'll go again three x squared in the X
became what I want well - lots of X to
the 1/3 X - what I in this case n is
just 1 so I've got I now minus 1 is 0 in
this case
now just pause for a second ok what have
we reached at this point does this look
familiar it should because we did about
five minutes ago right it corresponds to
this line okay so eyes ear is this let
me highlight that can you see why this
by zero corresponds to this line exactly
why is that well because I 0 is X to the
power of 0
AVX just just need to be X okay now at
this point I can stop I don't need to do
I need to use this returns relation evil
because I know at this integral is I
could just calculate it so I would say
that's X cubed in the X plus 3 lots of
this - - loss of this the integral of e
DX is just e DX and we already
calculated that was my very last
integral so I better slap a constant on
there
that's correct bit messy but so let's
just tidy it up I see a common factor of
4 terms they've all but neither the
excellent then okay what am I going out
the front I've got an X cube there I've
got minus 3x squared here I've got v3
that you're - that's plus 6x here and
then I've got negative negative negative
minus 6 then plus my constant
is that that try that guy so you can see
the way it worked right the recursion
here it makes this thing sort of long
over here which corresponds to my
working out sort of expanding as I'm
trying to resolve these integrals that I
don't know what they are but once you do
this once you integrate once you're
doing the same kind of integration
repeatedly okay so that's what you don't
need to do it all over again like we did
here
you continue to take advantage of the
pattern make sense